live local now and thank you for joining
us on 8 news now at five I'm Brian
Loftus I'm Denise Valdez Nevada
lawmakers back in Carson City today to
try to continue their debate on a bill
that would help bring A's baseball to
Las Vegas 8 news now reporter Brian will
joins us in studio with why there are
delays Brian Denise Bryant lawmakers
returned to Carson City today but they
haven't actually met and discussed the
bill at all it is sitting in the
assembly right now without having its
first vote yet negotiations from last
week and today are likely to bring
amendments to the bill before it goes up
for a majority vote those amendments
could include a community benefits
agreement and state senator Fabian
donate also floated the idea of making
the A's pay the live entertainment task
right now sports are exempt from that
tax lawmakers will likely come back with
some amendments for a community benefits
agreement the Democratic senator Edgar
Flores said that that bill for Allegiant
Stadium did have a benefits agreement
and was asking last week why there
wasn't any consideration of that for
this bill part of that Community
benefits analysis and and and kind of
what all of us who who were thinking of
supporting that idea we were thinking
we're also investing in something that's
already here and kind of saw that
partnership and so I'm curious why that
didn't carry over in the conversations
when we started talking about the A's
are coming here
the three-day break was badly needed
says assembly speaker Steve Yeager who
generated big interest in comments
posted on Twitter that said most of the
people he has heard from are not Nevada
ends he went on to say they gave
legislators and the staff the weekend to
rest as for what has happened today so
far just behind the scenes Talk they can
still meet and make some progress on the
bill this evening we also did receive a
traffic study on where that Tropicana
site for the ballpark could be which
includes minor work areas to improve
pedestrian access